back to the Browns we mentioned Baker
may feel the impact he's had on
Cleveland and I admire the ability Chris
of coaches and players to come up with
anything and everything they can to
create this sense that no one believes
in this remember the Patriots last year
Tom Brady after the divisional round win
over the Chargers
no one believes in this hey Tom
everybody believes in you who the hell
are you listening to we all believe in
you you win every game we know how it
goes especially in the postseason but if
that's what it takes to get you lathered
up so be it so bigger Mayfield talking
about the hype surrounding the Browns
and this comes courtesy of complex calm
I think in the media and everything that
comes with the hype around our team
right now people want to see us lose
just because the hype is so real because
we've got to go out there and take it
one week at a time we're trying to win
every week and I guess what he's saying
is and what he's trying to do is
convince his team that somehow some way
the world is against them so it's us
against the world even though the world
is saying hey the Browns gonna be pretty
damn good this year but you fashion
whatever you can into a chip on the
shoulder to keep your guys focused cuz
that's a worse thing Chris to have this
hype to have these expectations when
you've done nothing and everybody thinks
this team's gonna be great
at some point you got to show up week in
and week out and play the games yeah and
you got to do something to get the guys
attention so they don't just think all
we have to do is show up and we're gonna
win these games easily because they
could get caught flat-footed by a Titans
team that knows how to rise to the level
of the competition week one they could
get beat by the Jets week two and if
they go oh and - it's gonna be panic
time in Cleveland yeah and then the Rams
come in for Monday Night Football or
Sunday Night Football and week three so
you're right it would be panic time as
we talked about on the opening of the
you know the TV show before we came on
air here
you know Pires coaches they're looking
for edges they want an edge somehow some
way and yeah Baker Mayfield he's dumb
sure guys in the locker room oh nobody
believes in us and what really happens
at least in my assessment as far as an
athlete you block out a lot of the
positives so when you see like a
positive article or a pot of positive
headline and all those things you got
oh yeah but I don't want to hear it and
you just kind of move on but the
negative ones can catch your attention
and all of a sudden you start to see
that like what that kind of and you know
that can start to fire your fire you up
because the pot of isn't positive the
ones really you're kind of expecting as
an athlete and a high level athlete like
a baker Mayfield and all that they're
certainly gonna have a bull's-eye on
their chest we know that and I can say
from being there last week in training
camp man it was a different feel all
together that was my third time being in
Cleveland for training camp and there's
just a buzz but not just a buzz from the
fans Mike it's on the field there is a
certain confidence and edge about that
football team that you can feel that
filters down from Freddie kitchens right
down to Baker Mayfield and he filters it
through the offense and Steve Wilkes on
the defense so I I still I'm gonna pick
them to go to the playoffs I'm saying
that I'm gonna do it well and you know
it's funny and I guess what we can say
now is to all those teams out there that
we criticize from time to time you're
welcome we're giving them something
we're giving them something they don't
want positive there's enough positive
out there they don't want to hear the
pause if they would I have something
they can use to rally around to get
themselves fired up and early on in hard
knocks Tuesday night Jon Gruden talking
to his players about a lot of people out
there don't believe in this team Amir
you go that is gonna happen no matter
how good or bad you are there's always
gonna be something there that you can
focus on to keep your guys properly
locked in and this is the kind of stuff
that you need a quarterback to do
because if he's saying this kind of
thing publicly Chris you know privately
he is holding his guys accountable by
saying don't you get caught up in this
hype people want us to lose people can't
wait to see us fail this puts more
pressure on us than anything we've got
to go out there and deliver on what our
potential suggests that we can do
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports